how would you describe the mood in the
concept of party now so look of course
we have
um a great opportunity because we we
know that we're buzzing with ideas we've
got uh a lot of energy uh to get things
done still uh but uh of course there are
many many challenges facing the country
and by the way they'd be facing whoever
whomever was in power at this point in
time but the reason I say I think we've
got opportunities now is that uh we're
the party who you know has managed to
get unemployment very low people in work
and despite the very very tough times
we've looked after people through the
latest crisis which is the Ukraine war
by for example paying around half of
people's energy bills this winter so I
think we've got the ideas but also the
Practical Solutions uh not to say there
aren't many challenges along the way and
that's the pitch
but what's the mood like well look uh
I think that uh the mood is one of
Steely determination well I think we
think that we
um know that there's a job to do that we
are on the side of the British people
and you know whether that is getting
inflation halved or growing the economy
uh or reducing debt dealing with the NHS
waiting list okay and the rest of it
okay stopping the boats we're the ones
who are on the side of the public Steely
determination
um you've got these two mysterious
conferences that are sprung up right the
conservative Democratic organization in
Bournemouth yesterday the national
conservatism conference in London
tomorrow as far as I can tell the sole
purpose seems to be to give conservative
MPS a platform to give Russia kicking I
look I I just think a great party like
the conservative party who sort of
renews itself by buzzing with energy and
ideas
always welcomes the idea that people are
thinking through the problems that come
ahead when I was reselected as the
candidate the MP for the candidate for
well in Hatfield my own constituency my
own local
Association my own members wanted to
know what both what my ideas were and
tell them about their own and so it's
quite right for MPS to be able to meet
discuss ideas and then play those into
what will be a wider manifest it feels
like more than just discussing ideas
more than Steely determination doesn't
it look pretty Patel has said which is
who like Risk being responsible for the
managed decline of the conservative
party after the losses in the local
elections Nadine Dory said you'd had an
astonishing political tumble and you're
going backwards are they right well look
I I simply don't agree if you look at
any party after uh time in office if you
compared us with for example where Blair
and brown were through there period we
still have fun went on to lose
the point is we still have far more
counselors in place than they would have
done during the same point of the
Electoral cycle so this idea that
there's something written in the stars
that somehow we cannot come back and win
from our particular position at the
moment completely and fundamentally
disagree with and as I say the fact that
our MPS are still thinking of ideas
buzzing with energy uh buzzing with new
ideas that's a good thing not a bad
thing I guess listening to you
this feels like what some of these MPS
are worried about you've just had a
thousand over a thousand Council seat
losses right labor are on course to win
the next election all of the polling
says that and yet what you're hearing
from the top team is fingers and ears
we're just going to keep on delivering
no that's not what I think at all I mean
look first of all we've gone through an
enormous Global pandemic and that's been
expensive and then we've gone through
the Warren uh Ukraine uh and that's what
I mean
if I may you know this is what I kind of
mean because I've been hearing these
excuses from the conservative party for
you know the last year now on interviews
it feels like there should be a change
in tone and message after seeing Rishi
sunx first tested the Electoral box and
no no and this is where I think this is
where this is I think fundamentally
wrong the test was not as as you suggest
Rishi sunax first test at The Ballot Box
in that sense it was probably people
with the first opportunity to talk about
what was a fairly difficult period last
summer that people will remember and
this is the first time people have been
asked to go to The Ballot Box and I know
talking to my constituents many of them
have said look I just want to make the
point that I was not happy with what
happened last summer
but uh well we have these changes of
um of leadership and that's been very
well documented as as you know but
actually people realize this country has
gone through some pretty difficult times
and of course we won't have got
everything right but we have managed to
steer the country through it roll out
vaccines or provide up to half of
people's the typical uh Energy bill this
this winter wrapped our arms around and
tried to help people and uh that isn't
going to be easy to do but Rishi sunak
actually has stabilized the party I mean
I invite you to imagine all people who
think that to imagine what it might have
been like four or five six months ago if
the elections are being held there
unmanaged decline I just fundamentally
disagree and by the way I think if you
are sort of falling into or sharing the
idea that it's completely inevitable
that securment who one day to the next
simply doesn't even know what he
believes in but he'll always go where he
thinks uh it's convenient to go look at
the things he stood on to become leader
of the opposition which was a radical
left platform look at the things he's
saying now he'll say whatever left part
of this platform well of course he he
tried to appeal to Ascension but
generally what was what was the radical
part of this platform listed on well for
example a policy example for example he
stood on 10 different pledges many of
which was Radical left if you let me
answer the question many of which
carried on supporting uh some of the
policies that uh before him uh Corbin
had in place this is a man but what's
the radical left well let me talk to the
agenda this is a man who sat in the
corbyn shadow cabinet whilst
well and defended essentially therefore
Corbin's anti-Semitism he defended
Corbin's attacks on businesses uh and he
carried on playing not on and semitism
but in other areas to that agenda in his
10-point plan that got him elected then
dumps it and says no no uh I'm ready now
to to lead the country and again you
know today in in the newspapers we
learned that he has a plan uh to change
the electoral system uh to do to go
further than was the case for example
even when we were in the EU
even negotiate brexit again
just talking about that actually because
that is one of the things in the
newspapers today uh Kirsten apparently
uh looking at
um opening up the voting system so the
settled migrants for example EU citizens
who live work pay taxes in the UK could
get the vote along with 16 and 17 year
olds not something you support we don't
have any plans to change the electoral
system and again what he's actually
doing to put that in another to make
that clear he's reopening the brexit
settlement this is a settlement we have
made with EU countries to have
reciprocal arrangements so British
citizens can abroad are able to vote in
for example the local elections say in
Spain and the same here what he plans to
do is actually reopen the brexit
settlement so what else will he reopen
the The Windsor framework the the the
the corporation agreement with Europe uh
this again is kirst armor doing whatever
he thinks is practical uh to do at that
moment in time or in his personal
advantage to do at that point in time it
doesn't have fundamental ideas that he
relies on as I say stood on one platform
is now shifting to a different okay form
and he'll do the same with reopening
brexit it's clear that you want to talk
a lot about care stomach but I'm going
to talk about your own policies right
you're talking about promising one thing
and then doing another well let's have a
look at what you see next promise to
Scrap 4 000 EU laws why has he broken
his promise well those laws are being
scrapped uh 2 000 of which over 2000 of
which will be gone by the end of this
year uh the reality is as as the
libraries look for more of these laws
that were uh you know sort of almost
leftover pieces of law more are being
discovered in the archives as it were
and so there's a practicality of Simply
getting those through but uh you know
just this week
um the the business secretary put down I
think 600 more that will be scrapped
that will be over 2 000 scrapped by the
end of this year and we carry on that
process
um obviously not the fully at the full
pleasure to get all of them off the
statute book by the end of the year I
just want to read you something from
yesterday's times uh salsa said that
chaps
believe that the proposal to scrap or
reform all EU laws in the UK statute
book by the end of the year was entirely
doable and the good progress was being
made when he was in charge of the policy
well I should point out this is now
we're now several months on from when I
was a business secretary and looking
after this process so more of the laws
will have been uncovered because that
was the work that was going on and so
you've got to work with the practicality
is that Source correct though so no
you've got to work with what's there you
know in the time that you're actually in
that post so brexit ideology meeting
reality then well look I I was never a
sort of brexiteer in so not my ideology
but all I'm saying is uh things have
moved on now uh the current business
actually quite rightly be looking at the
body of laws there and working out how
best to take them off our statute but
here's the important principle here's
the important principle why does it even
matter well we've left the EU we
shouldn't therefore have laws that sort
of hang over and you know continue to
dictate the way that our country
operates people voted to leave I didn't
but lots of people did and so we
shouldn't have that on the statute but I
have every confidence the current
business secretary is looking at the
plethora of these laws that are left
she's going to have more than 2 000
scrap by the end of the year she's just
announced another 600 I think she's
doing this the right way okay and
there's been let's talk about
immigration shall we because there's
been an awful lot of focus on small
boats that are policy on Rwanda which
has affected exactly zero people so far
but I just want to have a look at what's
been happening to net migration I think
we can have a look uh now because we
have been seeing record levels of net
migration to the UK you can see they're
absolutely jumping uh recently and there
are reports that this number is set to
rise to even double to a million are you
in control of net migration you've just
completed two issues actually you've I
just want to sort of correct this you've
talked about small boats and then you've
talked about net migration yeah
absolutely these are two different
things the small boats are absolutely
right this is why I want to tell people
this is what I'm saying I'm saying that
immigration debate has been dominated by
small boats but actually I want to talk
about this legal migrations to the UK
that is skyrocketing look first of all
understand that 503 000 figures or these
larger numbers include hundreds of
thousands of people that you mean many
other people myself personally I've had
three of these people who've lived in my
house in these numbers here in the last
year the Ukrainian refugees and this
country has had a big heart we've opened
the the country for Ukrainian refugees
for British Nationals from Hong Kong
take those two groups alone and it's
well over three hundred thousand of
these numbers and then of course we've
had people from Syria and elsewhere so
actually I'm rather proud of our record
but I do just caution against conflating
two very different issues that's of
illegal absolutely immigration criminals
I'm just talking about illegal talking
about legal migration because there are
reports that this number could double
well is that okay I mean maybe it is
maybe you should say we should be
relaxed about no students about we have
we have uh a a migration advisory uh
committee that says look there's a
shortage in this area or that area one
of the advantages now with brexit is we
have control over our own policies so we
can say uh we we want people to help
with the specific sector but as I say
you and you'll remember this a year ago
a huge clamor to ensure that we're
providing Safe Haven to refugees from
Ukraine three of them lived in my house
so many other people brought were very
generous and brought people just to be
into their homes and that's included in
these numbers yeah just to be clear then
we should be relaxed in in your view
about high legal migration numbers even
if they hit a million okay well first I
don't think they're going to hit a
million and secondly uh the important
thing is that Britain has control and if
this country says so the question is
should we be relaxed by high levels of
net migration well we we should always
make sure that we only have people come
here uh that our rules and uh our our
policy bring here so if we say we are
going to invite people invite people
with grandfather rights from Hong Kong
to come and live here all ukrainians
unclear yes we should be relaxed with
high levels well the point is we should
we should be proud of our record where
it's people that we want here but we
should not allow people to come here
where it is illegal which is why it's
outrageous okay the kirst armor let's
not focus okay
okay
I will talk to the opposition about okay
but when you want to please do mention
to them they keep voting I want our
bills to stop this and it's very
important I thought we were completed
the two issues but thought about legal
migrations but you were talking about
illegal migration no I didn't I said
let's not talk about legal immigration
let's talk about legal money you started
off on the boats I started off I started
off on votes to say let's not talk about
the boats I just want to make it we are
making sure that we are stopping that
problem I would like to talk to you
about strikes if I may uh Pat Cullen at
the Royal College of Nursing demanding a
double-digit pay rise for her members is
that achievable I I find it this a very
curious story indeed um because Pat
Callum just recently was encouraging her
members to uh settle for the pay rise
that was put on the table uh that would
see 5000 pounds go into the pockets of
this year of our hard-working nurses I
thought this was a great settlement I
thought it's terrific that it had been
uh reached it's frankly rather confusing
uh now that having encouraged members to
accept that deal she seems to now be
coming back and saying the opposite
yes maybe she's coming back because her
members turned
I can't feel it was good enough well as
I say people will have to sort of Judge
this but five thousand Pounds into the
pocket of nurses more for people who are
a lower paid a good contribution because
in that role there's 20 employer
contribution to pensions as well and I'm
all in favor of this I mean I think our
our nurses work incredibly hard very
pleased to see that settlement reach but
I think it's a bit odd for the union
leaders who have said accept this and
then come back and say oh actually no we
now want to reopen something that she's
already accepted once and encourage her
members to accept so absolutely no two
double-digit pay rise then well as I say
you've got to balance that with the rest
of the public purse and there's a very
generous offer now on the table five
five grand uh you know this year would
be coming to nurses
um and I think that that would be a
great way to get this thing settled do
you take a bit of responsibility
yourself about setting the tone when it
comes to strikes and I'm just asking
because it feels to me like the train
operators were one of the first the rmt
sorry one of the first people to go on
strike when you were transport secretary
you didn't meet them you said don't risk
striking yourselves out of a job don't
pitch yourselves against the public
something the rmt said they thought was
a threat and now of course we have this
entrenched position with many of the
sides in the debate should you have
struck a more Conservatory tone well
look I just think with um Railways we'd
spent billions of pounds keeping the
railways going during um covid 40 of the
passengers haven't come back again uh to
the railways as yet
um and uh they're therefore having to be
propped up by huge taxpayer subsidy and
you've got a situation where train
drivers the aslift union for example are
on average paid nearly 60 000 pounds the
offer on the table puts it up to 65 000
pounds I just it's time to get this
thing put to bed
um on another issue if I may our Deputy
political editor at Sam Coates has been
investigating a conservative police and
crime commissioner Steve Turner now he
instigated or triggered two police
investigations into people that he was
his political opponents he was trying to
be a counselor in redcar
should there be an investigation into
what happened well look other than
having just heard about your reports I'm
not over the detail of this I'm not
familiar with the case itself and
obviously the process is to be followed
and I think it's important that those
are properly uh followed in the normal
way uh and independently I would suggest
to politicians getting involved in it
but it's important I guess to make sure
that local people who have local power
in areas like this should be out account
in the usual way yeah absolutely
um but as I said I want to sort of not
comment on something that you know there
is a proper process in place for those
kinds of Investigations uh now I
couldn't help but notice the
conservatives lost control of willing to
have for Council the local elections
majority but but you're a little bit
worried what you'll see I didn't win the
seat the first time I force it I always
treat it as a marginal and I know that
people have a choice how they vote so
I'm always always on top of that the
council as you say it's gone to know
overall control with the conservatives
by along with the largest party but I
never take it for granted never and uh
always work very hard for my
constituents as a result in well in that
field okay thank you very much indeed
thanks